무어의 법칙에 대해 이미 알고 계실 수도 있어요. 사실 이건 법칙이라기보다는 하나의 관찰이에요. '법칙'이라는 말은 제 생각엔 좀 농담 같은 표현이에요.
집적 회로, 즉 컴퓨터 칩 안의 트랜지스터 최대 개수가
약 2년마다 두 배씩 늘어난다는 거예요. 지난 약 50년간 우리는 이걸 관찰했을 뿐만 아니라 잘 활용해 왔어요.
트랜지스터가 많아질수록 더 빠르고 많은 계산을 할 수 있어요. 이게 본질적으로
컴퓨터가 시간이 지날수록 더 강력해지고 작아진 이유예요. 하지만 나쁜 소식이 있어요. 무어의 법칙이 죽어가고 있어요.
무어의 법칙이 언제 끝날지에 대해 전문가들의 의견이 엇갈리지만, 이미 끝났다고 말하는 사람들도 있어요. 정확히 언제
한계에 도달할지는 모르지만, 결국 불가피하다는 건 알아요. 트랜지스터의 일부 부품이
물리적으로 더 이상 작아질 수 없기 때문이에요. 예를 들어 원자보다 작은 트랜지스터는 만들 수 없잖아요.
물론 이건 물리적으로 완전히 불가능한 얘기예요. 우스운 것 같지만, 이게 바로 우리가 실제로 맞닥뜨린 한계예요. 그러면
그냥 포기하고 "이게 최선이야"라고 할까요? 아니죠, 인간은 절대 그런 적이 없어요. 다행히 양자
역학이 대화에 등장했어요. 양자 역학은 1920년대에 발견됐고, 그 이후로 세상은
말 그대로 완전히 달라졌어요. 그때 이뤄진 혁명적인 발견들에 대해 몇 시간도 이야기할 수 있지만,
이 강좌의 핵심은 그게 아니에요. 대신 양자
역학과 컴퓨팅이 이미 서로 양립할 수 있다는 걸 분명히 짚고 싶어요. 양자 역학에서 얻은
자연에 대한 발견과 이해가 오늘날의 컴퓨터를 가능하게 하는 데 일부 역할을 했어요. 양자
역학 없이는 솔리드 스테이트 하드 드라이브를 이해하거나 발명조차 못 했을 거예요.
Quantum computation은 이 진화의 자연스러운 다음 단계예요.
하지만 계산은 진공 속에 존재하지 않아요. 정보에는 매체가 필요해요.
정보를 계산하는 것은 물리 세계를 활용하고 또 그것에 영향을 미쳐요. 이것이 물리적으로 가능한 것에
한계를 두지만, 자연과 물리적 한계를 이해하는 것이 바로 물리학이라는 학문의 목표이기도 해요.
그래서 어떤 의미에서 물리학과 계산은 항상 서로 얽혀 있었어요. 컴퓨터 과학자이자 IBM 연구원이었던 Ralph Landauer는
수십 년 전에 정보는 물리적이라는 것을 인식했어요. 달리 말하면, 정보는
추상적인 실체가 아니라 물리적 표현을 통해서만 존재한다는 거예요. Landauer의 원리는
정보와 열역학 법칙 사이의 연결고리를 확립해요. 실제로 물리학과
계산 사이에는 많은 연결고리가 있어요. 최근까지 우리가 탐구할 수 있었던 건 고전 물리학뿐이었지만, 양자
역학의 발견으로 이제 완전히 새로운 방식으로 계산할 수 있는 시대의 문턱에 서 있어요. 이게 정말 좋은 이유는
고전 컴퓨터는 자연에서 실제로 일어나는 것을 근사치로만 계산할 수 있고, 어떤 경우엔 그 근사가 매우
제한적이기 때문이에요. 고전 물리학의 법칙을 따르는 기계가
양자 물리학의 법칙을 근사하게 만드는 건 정말 어렵거든요. 자연은 고전적이 아니라 양자적이에요. 이해를 돕는 비유로
풍동을 생각해 볼 수 있어요. 유체 역학은 수학적으로 시뮬레이션하고 예측하기가 굉장히 어렵기로 유명해요.
바람 속을 달리는 자동차처럼 평범한 것조차도요. 자동차 제조사들은 자동차를 설계할 때
이 물리적 상호작용을 시뮬레이션하려고 하면 너무 비용이 많이 들고 비현실적이라는 걸 발견했어요. 그래서
실제로 바람을 불어넣는 터널을 만들어서 차를 그 안으로 몰고 들어가
어떻게 되는지 확인하는 방법을 택했어요. 이게 제가 고전 컴퓨터가 자연을 형편없이
근사할 뿐이라고 할 때의 비유예요. 바람을 시뮬레이션하는 대신
연구자들이 그냥 바람을 재현하는 것처럼, 양자 컴퓨터도 분자 수준에서 자연의 법칙을 근사할 필요가 없어요.
그 법칙을 본질적으로 따르기 때문이에요. 시뮬레이션이 아니라 에뮬레이션이에요. 배터리나 화학 반응을 시뮬레이션할 때도
똑같은 어려움이 생겨요. 이게 다음 섹션으로 이어지는데,
Quantum Computing은 무엇에 유용한가예요.
왜 양자 역학과 컴퓨팅을 결합하려는 걸까요? 이미 최첨단 슈퍼컴퓨터조차
풀기엔 너무 어렵고 계산 비용이 너무 많이 드는 문제들이 있어요.
연구자들만 집중하는 문제처럼 보일 수 있지만, 그 영향은 전 세계에 미칠 수 있어요.
고전 컴퓨터가 막히는 이런 문제들은, 우리 사회가 기술에 점점 더 의존하게 되고
배터리 효율, 금융 모델링, 최적화 같이 진정으로 중요하게 여기는 분야와 관련이 있어요.
그리고 더 나은 비행기를 만드는 방법도요. 양자 컴퓨터로 눈을 돌리는 이유는, 여기에 엄청난 잠재력이 있고
가장 강력한 슈퍼컴퓨터조차 닿을 수 없는 새로운 계산의 문을 열 수 있다고 믿을 만한 충분한 이유가 있기 때문이에요.
이론적으로 일부 양자 알고리즘은 특정 응용 분야에서 최선의 고전 알고리즘보다 우위를 제공해요.
다른 응용 분야에서는, 노이즈와 불완전함이 있더라도 양자 컴퓨터가 고전적인 브루트
포스 솔루션과 경쟁하는 도구로 사용될 수 있다는 증거가 점점 쌓이고 있어요.
기본적으로 완전히 새로운 도구이고, 이걸로 더 멋진 것들을 할 수 있는 방법을 찾고 싶어요. 또한
Feynman이 처음 제안한 아이디어, 즉 물리학과 자연 자체를 이해하는 데 활용하는 것도 생각해볼 수 있어요.
결국 자연은 고전적이 아니라 양자적이라고 이미 말씀드렸잖아요. 이 분야는 믿을 수 없을 만큼 풍부하고 매혹적이며
학제간이에요. 물리학, 컴퓨터 과학, 정보 처리, 그리고 물론 우리가 관심 갖는 특정 응용 분야들을 한데 아우르죠.
하지만 고전 컴퓨터와 달리, 모든 사람이 주머니 속에 양자 컴퓨터를 가지고 다니진 않아요.
아주 최근까지도, 양자 컴퓨터를 실험하려면 직접 만들고 유지보수해야 했어요.
보통 대학교나 연구 시설의 지하 실험실에서요. 제가 잘 알고 있어요. 하지만 이제는 그렇지 않아요.
2016년에 IBM이 최초의 양자 프로세서를 클라우드에 올렸어요. 당시엔 qubit이 5개뿐이었고
오류율도 꽤 높았지만, 그게 불과 8년 전이에요. 지금 얼마나 많이 발전했는지 보세요. 오늘날 우리의 현황은 어떨까요?
현대 컴퓨터 초창기와 비교할 수 있는 점이 많아요. 말씀드렸듯이 이건 매우
어려운 도전이고, 최첨단 연구소나 시설에서 일하는 사람들 외에는
양자 컴퓨터가 널리 보급된 지 불과 8년밖에 안 됐어요. 하지만 그 8년 동안 모든 면에서 발전을 이뤄왔어요.